hallo ja kommen Sie rein grüß
Gott ja wo ist der Patient ja ber kommst
du re gleich da
komm da
komm ja wen haben Sie uns den da
mitgebracht ja das ist der ber ber ja
und ihm geht nicht
gut Frau D hilft
gleich ein Saugroboter ja aber wischen
kann auch also gerade für gegen
Tierhaare ist der sehr sehr gut
aber ich habe mir seit paar Wochen die
die Frau Doktor hilft da schon
eigentlich bin ich nur für für ja sie
war schon so Hunde und Katzen und so wie
we nicht wo ich hingehen soll mit ihm
bitte wennm anschauen könnten bitte na
gut das erzählt einem im Studium
keiner die Frau Doktor hilft schon also
was genau ih denn eine
Hausstauballergie
nein was wä schon Fehlen der Saugroboter
hat gefressen wer hat wen gefressen der
Saugroboter hat meinen Zwerghamster
gefressen was den
sonst die Frau Doktor hilft dir keine
Angst halte durch ich ma mich gleich me
OP
fertig
[Musik]